come in guys we gotta go home but you
gotta get up out of here this might be a
strike against me as their we're gonna
get married you made an honest woman out
of me I'm gonna be moving into your
place oh you're gonna be coming into my
space mmm on my time and I'm gonna have
to accommodate another human being yeah
but do you see yourself ever getting
married in life I think right now I'm at
the point where like yeah it'd be cool
to be like I think living with somebody
I don't know if I'm necessarily ready to
be married and that's what's putting in
the better on the couch I don't put me
on the couch okay so I'm about to move
in with destiny so I have to pack and I
am the world's worst Packer I have way
too many socks and underwear but you
never know because like accidents
happens honey I'm home like I know
you're a bit of a neat neat freak
apparently I've gotten worse oh you
cleaned my first thing I do when I come
home is take off my clothes and they
usually just live
so I'm about to take my shoes off and
doesn't leave them anyway that's not my
style I'm not your mama I will not clean
up behind you yeah my mommy my wife oh
that does not compromise that is you
just tell me where to put my shoes okay
it's right here what like what do you
you mean like you wake up and where are
you I'm out by 4:30 at the gym until
6:30
[Music]
get off that boy oh no what oh my god
I'm supposed to be the opposite now I
usually wake up about 8:45
oh no have coffee meditate work till
6:00 and then I'm usually up reading or
journaling or knitting or something
until like 1:00 in the morning
oh yeah I'm an item more usually last
night I go to bed at 8 o'clock welcome
you to dinner before 7:00 oh no I don't
even start cooking before 7:00 so I was
reading the book before bed and destiny
hopefully and that guilt bags I don't
wanna wake her up so I know I'm just
sleeping on the couch and so I was half
sleep half not cuz I was like well I
need to make sure I'm like not sprawled
out when he comes to the bed and he
never came it's exam second night was
when you decided to get up with me and
we were gonna do our makeup together and
I was like yeah if I made us late we
were a solid hour - halfway to work look
at me
we woke up this morning
how later we know okay well good night -
I was working really late my husband
left me I did all day waiting for him
out a door oh right and I work different
schedules so I knew I was gonna come
home and like have some downtime but it
has now been an hour and a half since he
was supposed to be off work and I've
heard nothing from him not hey I'll be
home at this time
oh no I guess that's marriage sitting at
home till your significant other gets
home I was working really late and I was
like I was trying to figure out what
we're gonna do for dinner
and then I ended up having another
friend come it's way past when Ryan was
supposed to be home it's off like well
I'm just gonna be comfortable than the
male will come when he comes but then I
can expect much thing let's go get
dinner the things you do for them and I
was hanging out with another woman with
they two we're not even past on a
honeymoon we're here not definitely not
how do you feel about this we made like
I'm a part of it okay
a threesome I throw up all your
sister-wives but he did he did pay for
food so so there's that so tonight's
date night and I was supposed to plan a
big thing for me and destiny and like
any responsible adult I completely
blanked and didn't plan much I'm gonna
try to see if I can get away with doing
like an at-home spa day I was thinking
at first I was gonna do like a bunch of
things but I like I know that destiny is
not somebody who likes to like go out
and do a lot of things like you're chill
you just want to be at home and relax
hopefully she likes it I honestly don't
know and
be a strike against me as a husband well
I was like you know what I'm home early
and I want to like surprise you when you
get home and have dinner made I'm going
to make breakfast for dinner because
breakfast food is all I have in here I
couldn't think of a slick way to ask
when he was coming home so I was just
like when are you coming home and he was
like probably around like 7:00 by the
way do you like sushi
he dropped the bomb on me so I was like
uh maybe we should just grab sushi
tomorrow and like it groceries today I
don't know if that works when you asked
if I like sushi I was like HM hmm
I think today is date night date night
how did you forget date enough okay I
just hope that he doesn't do me like he
did yesterday and stay out all day and
then be like hey come meet me years of
her food come you know all right cooked
for us although I personally despise
breakfast for instance I'm gonna hurt
you
orange juice and she paid for mimosas
some fruit I even stopped and not get
potatoes I love hashbrowns I know that
destiny doesn't like potatoes cuz I
listen yeah and by then everything has
been cooked and print in the I was
trying to surprise you sleep
Leslie trying to surprise me made
breakfast for dinner me trying to
surprise destiny bot baby really my
heart is so warm right now
you all domestication fear so I got us
masks so we can relax I got you shave
you are so pretty and I told you I was
afraid you were gonna be like a lot of
energy that I was gonna have to keep up
with but I was very surprised the entire
time most people think that I'm like
high-energy all the time like the longer
you around me the more you realize are
like I'm pretty dot I have chill moment
yeah yeah we look like we about to go
rob a bank
I think we just get each other and get
each other's energy I'm keeping you up
you now no no no you think honestly I
enjoyed having you around so much I
really just I was like looking forward
to you coming home communication is key
yeah and that because we were both
trying to think do what the other person
we thought the other person wanted to do
instead of just being like what would
you what do you think you what do you
mean oh you're ready ready - I was
thinking like Tim well - marriage -
marriage yes for the right one I'm
single again y'all
[Music]